[Music]
Robert Spencer here for Jihad watch a
program of the David harwitz Freedom
Center and for the center for security
policy Christmas 2016 has passed having
taken place amid unprecedented security
measures all over Europe and North
America this past Year's tense and
nervous Christmas however was just the
beginning get used to it because thanks
to feck to the point of suicidal
immigration policies in Europe and North
America Christmas is going to be like it
was in 2016 for many years to
come the mail online in the UK reported
on Christmas Day 2016 that the West has
been put on increased Terror alert over
the festive period following the Berlin
Lori tragedy security has been ramped up
in major cities including London New
York Paris Vienna and dorf as fears grow
of another ISIS attack on the west
tanks were seen in the streets of
Budapest Hungary and soldiers were
pictured at the Christmas markets in
Anor Belgium the Metropolitan Police has
said it is to review its plans for
protecting public events over Christmas
and New Year following the awful
incidents in Berlin and
ankora the extra security was justified
not only did jihadis Target the
Christmas Market in Berlin but there
were six other Terror plots and attacks
in the runup to Christmas Day 2016
we have to step back and ask why did
this happen why were tanks in the
streets of Budapest guarding Christmas
markets why is the entire Western World
on edge on a more or less constant basis
now because European and North American
authorities have admitted large numbers
of Muslim migrants into their countries
among whom are unknowable numbers of
jihad terrorists and allowed Sharia
enclaves to grow in which hatred of
unbelievers and the necessity to w war
against and subjugate them is taught
Christmas and other holidays widely
celebrated in Western countries are
under siege because there are large
numbers of Muslims in the west that is
the sole and only reason the
responsibility lies with those who
admitted them without regard for Islam's
doctrines of religious Warfare and
supremacism and yet they have made these
doctrines quite clear in August 2014
Amel shimun Nona the caldian Catholic
Archbishop of mosul Iraq predicted that
all of this would happen after Islamic
jihadists de decimated the Christian
population of his area Nona issued a
prophecy our sufferings today he said
are the Prelude of those you Europeans
and Western Christians will also suffer
in the near future and so in 2016 as the
few remaining Christians in the Middle
East celebrated Christmas and hoped that
Muslims would not murder them for doing
so that future is now Nona continued I
lost my dasis the physical setting of my
apostolate has been occupied by Islamic
radicals who want us converted or dead
he explained that the West was making a
grave error by assuming that Islam was a
religion of peace that taught the equal
Dignity of all human beings he said
please try to understand us your liberal
and Democratic principles are worth
nothing here you must consider again our
reality in the Middle East because you
were welcoming in your countries an Ever
growing number of Muslims also you are
in danger you must take strong and
courageous decisions even at the cost of
contradicting your principles you think
all men are equal but this is not true
Islam does not say that all men are
equal your values are not their values
if you do not understand this soon
enough you will become the victims of
the enemy you have welcomed in your
home you will become victims of the
enemy you have welcomed in your home and
now here we are what will future
Christmases in Europe look like unless
suicidal policies regarding Muslim
migration are reversed they will look
like Christmases in Islamic lands where
Christians gather with the constant
awareness that this could be the day
that Islamic jihadis decide to punish
them for the crime of being infidels
Muslims threw a grenade at a church in
mindo a Muslim majority area of the
Philippines during Christmas Eve Mass
2016 injuring 16 people that was not the
first and it will not be the last could
it happen here the Islamic State Isis
certainly hoped so several days before
Christmas 2016 it published the names
and addresses of thousands of churches
in the United States calling on Muslims
to attack them surely these churches
have nothing to worry about right if
they don't have any clergy or
parishioners who've drawn Muhammad stood
up for the freedom of speech or
otherwise provoked the poor deers or
poked them in the eye right surely the
churches that have pursued dialogue with
Muslims even at the cost of remaining
silent about the Muslim persecution of
Christians and abandoning those
Christians to their fate have nothing to
worry about do they the Islamic State
will surely see how accommodating
they've been and spare them now won't it
surely the Islamic State will go easy
with cowards and appeasers won't it no
it won't that list was not acted upon in
2016 but the more Muslims enter the US
the more jihadis will be among them and
the more Christians will be under threat
for the sake of Christmas then the
promised immigration reforms that the
Trump Administration has said are coming
cannot come a moment too soon I'm Robert
Spencer
[Music]